las pirámides de Egipto aún tienen
secretos por revelar tras un año de
excavaciones en la necrópolis de esa
cara cerca del santuario de bastet que
tenía catacumbas con gatos momificados
fueron desenterrados talleres de
momificación humana y animal incluyendo
las herramientas que utilizaban los
egipcios en esos años
Esta es la primera vez que descubrimos
un taller de embalsamamiento asociado
con templos todos los talleres
anteriores estaban vinculados a
episemensis lo que significa que es un
descubrimiento importante encontrar un
taller de embalsamamiento en saqara
en tanto que también dieron que en el
arte de la época como una colección de
estatuas de madera y hallaron dos tumbas
de sacerdotes que tienen pinturas y
están talladas uno Data de la quinta
dinastía del reino Antiguo y el otro de
la dinastía décimo octava del reino
tardío alrededor de 2.400 años atrás
y las inscripciones de la tumba son tan
asombrosas representan la vida religiosa
y secular debido a sus títulos podemos
ver escenas de la agricultura La cosecha
el pastoreo la matanza sacrificial y la
cría de animales todas esas escenas se
encuentran en la tumba el calando
Egipto ha lanzado operaciones
arqueológicas en saqqara y otros lugares
antiguos en los últimos años con el fin
de revivir el turismo conectado por la
agitación política de 2011 y logrando
descubrimientos del alto